post KN able to pick up the loose Puck after the
centering pass one a stray here's Marshon in the
Montreal zone drop pass a chance for lorai triy
to feed it to Marshon who takes the puck off the
boards back to makoy takes a look with a rot TI
down pav zaka I think got a piece of it and the
Bruins Take the Lead just 36 seconds into this
game Bea and Jennifer vadal before the game
talking about defensive coverage uh the Canadians
get running around and here's this shot tipped by
Zach in everybody's deep nobody has a point man
and the point man has so much time to let it go
and you can see all the bodies lined up in front
and a zaka that gets his stick on it and up and
over Sam mono pass down Puck tipped in Deep by
Cole cof Suzuki and carfield for the second game
in a row playing on separate lines for Montreal
here's a turnover chance in front and save there
as Christian dorak had a chance and San able to
make the Stop and cover the puck out of swords
in the corner Puck Center steam couldn't get it
on goal Pearson chops out he gets it out and here
comes Maham with gallager Shan Maham slows shoots
stop gallager the rebound couldn't put it home
back strike to Gallagher but he couldn't finesse
it into the net cuts across the slot with a wrist
shot blocked and petta starts out for Montreal
feeds back into his own Zone giv it away passing
off shoots left P save by monten Mitchell cross
to forber his pass blocked by Coffield but he
gets it through on the second attempt Puck sent to
the middle Jabron shoots off the post stick side
he beat monteno but rang it off the goal post
Poston goes across but it's off a stick and out
to Center Pearson was giving Chase now Gallagher
steps in and gets the puck on the right wing drop
pass Monahan Cuts in front Monahan shoots hit the
post posts at both ends Canadians on a couple in
this period and it's still one- nothing Boston and
then it was [Music] Monahan who gets a neat pass
back from Marshon Bruins with numbers lur in over
the line poov cuts to the middle dishes off oh
what a stop by monbo got the left pad on that one
timer by bra marshaw checked by Monahan good work
by the veteran G the puck to the line couldn't
get it out Dan rste Costo backhander off the arm
of monbo matys in the little room Bobble the puck
for a moment now feeds down to Coffield up to mat
Suzuki at the right Point fires down into the
corner Monahan shot by Anderson fought off by
Swan mats walks the line wrist shot hit a
body in front again that ruins had the puck
failed to clear now they going to be another
P delay call Suzuki here's Monahan loose pu
Monahan sto by Swan on aead passes back to
[Applause] mat Coffield to M here's Suzuki
to the side SL on the S this one's been
getting an intermission so fast only 24
faceoffs in the game the record for fewest in
a game this season's 35 there's a goal shot by
Suzuki now they break [Music] through Nick
Suzuki on the power play 24 seconds into
the third and the game's tied at one it's
going to be traffic in front Canadians do
a nice job get some traffic in front you see
manah hands in front there's that long shot
and Monahan at the last seconds just slides
out of the way it hits sw's shoulder and goes
in Nick Suzuki matches his career high
that's goals in four straight games now
back to Gul in for Gallagher again checked
immediately in the corner keeps after the
puck edmans is there as well feeds it back
gie Ed gie long shot Gall three [Applause]
outs two goals in 27 seconds and Montreal's
taking the lead long shot and just get it
through gly takes a shot and Gallagher's in front
ticks it knocks it down and then slides it around
he is so good at getting body position here he
is makoy is trying to front him Gallagher knocks
it down and makoy you can see just in behind him
doesn't have him he's trying to front him doesn't
knock it down Gallagher does behind the net slap
kovski feeds along for Dvorak who put the puck
in front ruins break that and here comes loo to
beer who stood up by kich as he played the puck
here lco gets it back Mitchell long shot to down
Bruins answer right back that one was deflected at
the side get in position in the Bruins for check
Jen talked about the Canadian for check there's
a bruin for che making a count and you can see
SK picked that one out of the air Sam monmo was
hoping that it was high but it's not it's well
below the crossbar you can see monmo looked over
at the referee right away buly interference is
challenging the play to see if there was goer
interference PRI to the goal yeah he bumps him
knowing how poorly you do with your football pick
so I got to congratulate the allet how about that
upset here we go we have a decision here's Chris
Lee to the Montreal coaches CH tourament there
was goal tender first therefore we have no goal
pu turn over the Blue Line Frederick in front of
the back hand van re St was there but couldn't
finesse it past s mson m over the Boston L good
job came the Zone with control with then his pass
he's intercepted by forward he sends beer John
beer to the net mble to set and the shorthanded
bit Canadians getting in the way of the puck so
far 10 seconds to go in the four three that one
thrown on goal and gloved by Monson book who
hangs on to stop play and he was eventually
able to get it to Mike matth who starts out on
the far side indirect pass here's Suzuki Nick
Suzuki centers Anderson oh a GL save [Applause] by
maoy gets the puck of the blue L here's pasta to
the net go and they're talking kicked in can you
imagine I think this was an angled in Maron van re
both in the neighborhood as posto put that one in
front he at the side of the [Applause] net that's
that's not a kicking Motion in my estimation
that's an angle he angles his scape so that
it's it's tipped too it's tipped before it
gets to Brad Baran and he's got his skates
angled so that it'll kiss off and go in i i dorak
intercepts and back hands the puck [Applause]
out poon up brings it back into his own Zone
loses the Pu to Coffield fan on a sharp angle
bid now stopped by San off The Bard here's a one
timer by Coffield and that one off the shoulder of
Swing 25 seconds into overtime can
Caufield do it again it's maton now
nice move in STO by swam as he tried to
put it between the legs gie ahead to new
in with Anderson takes the pass Josh
Anderson nice move to the middle new
[Applause]
[Music] hook
the streak is over this down but look at this
Rush by Anderson to the middle makes a good
play office impact there's G rolling
pet has a deflect up and over Jeremy
Sweden Swan Swan is just guessing now he's
looking he can't find it there's two Bruins
in front ghouly jumps up why not he's the
last man he's still got time if he has to